[Music]
hi my name is Brenda Cantrell and I'm
trained ambassador and plane baggage
Jenna we kind of say you got weird
amusement park of shopping you just it's
it's a fun thing to do it's a fun place
to come and it's a lot of fun people to
be around so unrelated centers started
almost 50 years ago in a tiny town in
Alabama and now it's the national
tourism destination and when people come
in they just truly never know what
they're going to find
[Music]
you can tell the people that have never
been here before when they just walk a
few steps into the store and they just
stop and look around in amazement you're
shocked at the sheer size of our
building it's over 40,000 square feet
and we cover a city block but we stalk
about five to seven thousand unique
items to ourselves for every day some of
the craziest things that we have found
but of course top the list is live
rattlesnake the mummified Falcons we've
had in the past headdresses that are
very old things that belong to
celebrities at one point vacuum tight
frogs and a suitcase probably take the
gate another interesting thing is the
movie labyrinth the character hoggle is
actually in our showcase there was only
one night for that movie and there's a
cult following for that and we have
Huggle here in our showcase the found
treasures are really just a highlight of
your time here in the stores
so this is just our Unclaimed Baggage
experience before it gets picked
together a nonprofit bag early on first
don't sound happy at Con Thien if you
think about using Carnival embarrassing
or dangerous but other than that it's
strictly a nonprofit bag for Main Street
detraction give it away accelerate our
equipment we put about 80,000 items a
month which is more than average
laundromat that's an entire year
[Music]
we feel pieces that are $10,000 every
way that's not uncommon for us to sell
something like that
yeah put it on $21,000 on my wrist right
now who would leave this in a suitcase
that's crazy
the single most expensive item that
we've ever had it on our sales floor
it's a men's presidential platinum Rolex
watch we had it appraised and it was
valued at $64,000 and a gentleman bought
it for 32,000 but I'm like can you
imagine not only being the person that
owns this but the person who like forgot
it it's just like wow that's goals oh it
is it Abdo it
Ouiser you supposed to sit like there
[Music]
that's good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]